the latest bogus covid treatment slash
prophylactic slash cure it's all of the
above in reality it's none is inhaling
hydrogen peroxide through an asthma
nebulizer now I'm going to say it a
number of times throughout this segment
to remain in compliance this is a bad
idea not evidence-based not recommended
by actual doctors and can be very
harmful to your health so don't nebulize
hydrogen peroxide through asthma
inhalers I'm merely telling you that
there are people doing it last week we
talked about so-called urine therapy
um which involves drinking urine rubbing
it on your skin uh using it in a Neti
Pot you know it it's it does not do
anything for covid despite what that
crazy guy I told you about last week
says the new one is inhaling uh
aerosolized I guess we would call it
hydrogen peroxide this is wildly
spreading and uh I it's crazy because we
we had this long weekend
I checked back in on the news when we
get back from the long weekend and all
of a sudden hydrogen peroxide inhalation
is everywhere so here's one guy
explaining how the hydrogen peroxide
protects him not only from covid but
from people shedding vaccine on him
which is a whole other insane widely
debunked thing and again as a
pre-disclaimer essentially nothing that
you're going to hear in this clip is uh
accurate so let's take a listen it is
there's been a lot of Articles saying oh
this is terrible for you don't ever do
this don't ever inhale uh nebulized
hydroperoxide but Hydra peroxide uh if a
doctor's going to go on and actually say
to do this uh you know I trust in the
one doctor uh again I forget his name
but uh I'll post the video there's one
Doctor Who is saying to do this and the
guy doesn't remember that doctor's name
but all the other ones are saying don't
he trusts the one doctor whose name me
doesn't remember Leo's Mercola has a
conversation with him
um in a rumbling and by the way anytime
you hear the name Dr Mercola head for
the hills folks they're also on bed
shoot where they talk about the guy's
been [ __ ] shoot what on Earth is
happening doing this since the 90s now
he also utilizes uh
uh iodine
um puts like a drop the iodine thing
also was floating around a few months
ago that's totally debunked as well dine
into the into the medicine bottle here I
haven't tried that yet I'm gonna try it
uh I'm actually got someone order and
see the iodine that they're recommending
I think is it costs like nine bucks for
two little balls doesn't this guy just
Inspire confidence in terms of Medical
Treatments roles or something like that
so again there are different ways to do
it but I find that this is the easiest
way plus you got it like you know in the
fridge and it's ready to go so whenever
I go to a rally or I'm going to a
restaurant or I went to the movies the
other night and stuff like that uh and
you know I don't ever wear a mask so uh
right not that they help but I the first
thing I do is I come in and I put one of
these on isn't that brilliant he says I
do this because I don't ever wear a mask
even though the masks don't help well
then why do you need to do something in
lieu of wearing a mask like ever you
could animal lies every sentence and it
wouldn't make any sense also I don't
have to wait for that to be honest with
you when I get up in the morning I do
this and since then I haven't been taken
any antihistamines uh anything like that
I haven't been taking any cold
medication I haven't had any like
congestion
my sleep has been a lot better
um I I I and I attribute it to this now
I want to point something out as a and
he says this is the only thing that I've
done this he attributes it to this any
time this this starts this is a very
common thing in general in the kind of
quack cures thing
which is they start to tell you it
basically cures and treats everything
you know and this has been floating
around for a long time and it's
everything from you know you can find
that drinking colloidal silver it it's
basically it treats everything or uh
pomegranate or anytime something treats
so many conditions and and deals with so
many symptoms aside from the fact that
this is not a medical professional you
we should all be skeptical and really
different so
um nebulizer unless it's like you know
maintaining a regimen of a good diet
exercise going outside every single day
it's like yes that all together that
entire lifestyle is good for a lot of
different things but whenever it's like
hydrogen peroxide treats all these
things we should be very skeptical for
80 bucks 90 with tax uh I would say
eight to ten dollars for for the food
grade 12 hydrogen peroxide for 100 bucks
I think it's it's worth it and again
like I said I I went to the movies The
other nights in Pasadena you don't have
to show a vax card and we didn't wear a
mask and uh we're in the you know in
there with a bunch of you know backed
out people shedding all over us and
everything like that even though they
got masks on I put you know first thing
I did as soon as I got home is I hit
this takes about 10 minutes to to go to
the end here and uh you can watch TV
while you're doing it it's not that
obtrusive so he's using it interesting
to protect himself not only from the
virus but also from vaccine shedding
which again we we've debunked all of
this so do not inhale hydrogen peroxide
okay Healthline has published
extensively on this
um it can hurt your lungs it won't
prevent covid
um there is a quote from
uh the aafa which is the Asthma and
Allergy Foundation of America they said
hydrogen peroxide can be used as a
cleaner and stain remover and can cause
tissue damage if you swallow it or
breathe it in Dr Len horvitz who's a
nationally recognized pulmonary
specialist said
um that this could seriously harm people
quote the very beginning of this let's
talk about things that are ridiculous
way back in March of 2020 I had a
patient send me something from what
seemed to be a scientific study that
explained the virus is inactivated by
heat and suggested putting a hair dryer
up to your nose five minutes every day
maybe they were just trying to sell hair
dryers uh don't do this guys it's
extraordinarily dangerous it's a very
very bad idea and what's endlessly
fascinating as a as a sort of detached
Observer is they seem determined
to try anything other than the vaccine
which we know is very likely to keep you
out of serious covet
anything else they'll try iodine
hair dryer up your nose
nebulized hydrogen peroxide urine
therapy but we've got the vaccine it's
FDA approved it works really well at
preventing serious illness and yet that
they don't seem to want it's truly
incredible it's like they're determined
to thin themselves out either by getting
covered and dying or by using dangerous
so-called treatments which are not
actually treatments and again just as a
reminder this is an unproven treatment
that shouldn't be called a treatment
that can hurt you so do not nebulize
hydrogen peroxide
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
cometeer coffee is delicious I can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their Brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home Frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that I have ever made coffee I've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor I really enjoy cometeer they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
Blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty Roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometeer.com
Pacman the link is underneath this video